i've never seen the river as low as this
stefan marty tells me he's a fisheries
officer in a normal year the level of
the garan here would be above our heads
the river cuts through toulouse it's the
city's lifeblood providing drinking
water irrigating farmland and cooling a
nuclear plant
stefan has had to take fish out of the
river and put them into special tanks
because the water is too warm
it's complicated everything is connected
there will be less snow in the mountains
the glaciers will melt sooner this year
there has been much less snow so less
water in the mountain lakes so pumping
of the lakes is lower to keep the water
longer over three weeks forty percent of
the water held in reserve in
hydroelectric dams in the pyrenees
mountains has been released into the
goron to keep it flowing
just
heat waves in europe are increasing at a
faster rate than almost anywhere else on
the planet and global warming increases
the likelihood of drought drying out
soils and vegetation
minimum sources
we need 60 millimeters of rainfall to be
able to replant the soil cristel
carpentier tells me the forecast is for
three millimeters this week
it's not enough
[Laughter]
the corn harvest across france is
expected to be eighteen and a half
percent lower this year than last
there's already a global shortage
because of the war in ukraine
even the sunflowers have turned away
from the scorching sun
where there is access to water there
isn't enough to go around christelle
says she'll lose more than 30 percent of
her crop this year
if we don't get enough water in this
region there will be no viable
agriculture even today the cattle
farmers here have no grass on their
fields today we are on a land where it's
crucial to develop irrigation
if only to be able to achieve minimum
profitability
france's worst drought since records
began in 1958 has affected so many
aspects of how people live here and i
think we
we will work a lot
we will
train the kayak
and we will walk because there is not
enough water for for the floating
in july rainfall across france was down
84 compared to normal according to the
french weather service
the summer isn't over yet
i'm standing on the bed of the river
goron and obviously in normal times i
shouldn't be able to do this every part
of france is under some sort of water
restriction and two-thirds of all french
departments are at crisis level the most
severe level and there is now particular
concern for the underground water tables
because they are being used up more
quickly because there isn't enough snow
melts and rain water to refill them